well I think I think the biggest thing
for pharmaceutical and biotech companies
is to think about not necessarily the
dissemination of a message but as a way
to start a relationship with key
public's and key stakeholders a lot of a
lot of what goes on with industry
science in relationship to the public is
a matter of trust building and
relationship building and that can be
done through transparency and
accessibility to information but also
engaging in dialogue the type of town
meetings science cafes where interested
members of the public can turn out and
hear about the science that goes on at
pharmaceutical companies and
biotechnology companies but also also
hear from experts who are experts on the
ethics involved the regulation that's
involved in the policy in the legal
issues and not just hear from them but
also present their own viewpoints and
enter into a conversation not only is it
informational but its relationship
building it can also be fun I've also
suggested I think documentary film is a
good way to present the complexity of a
lot of these scientific regulatory and
ethical questions and documentary film
can be used in these type of town hall
meetings where people come out watch a
short documentary film that presents the
complexities issues and maybe kind of
shows multiple perspectives from
patients and from companies from
scientists and then have a panel and
kind of town hall meeting discussion
about the issues that were raised in the
documentary film
well you know I think that's a the
direct-to-consumer marketing is very
good for getting getting the attention
of patients an increasing awareness
about the availability of certain types
of drugs and certainly they're going to
pay attention to it if that drug is
specific to something that they might
have related to a disease or that they
might suffer from a family member might
suffer from on the other hand i'm not
sure what it does in terms of enhancing
the public perception of the
pharmaceutical industry relative to
regulation or right relative to public
policy or in terms of trust a
relationship building and i think other
mechanisms and other modes of
communication or definitely needed it to
achieve those goals
well you know I think you know in the
short term what we can do with an adult
population there that is done with their
formal education is we can figure out a
way to use the media to engage with them
to present complex issues in ways that
they understand and that matters to them
as personally relevant that's probably
the best we can do but in the long term
we need to certainly continue to invest
in really strong formal education and
science about the scientific method
about the facts in the context in the
history of science but also I think at
the college level especially students
need to learn about the sociology of
science the role that the institution of
science plays in our society how its
funded the politics of science kind of
the social side of how science is done
you know scientists work within
institutions institutions have their own
imperatives and also a media literacy
component how does the media cover
science what are really good sources to
read and enjoy science once you're done
with your formal education and science
and in that way we're achieving two
things one we're providing a
college-educated American public with
the context that they need to be
scientific citizens to make informed
choices about science policy but the
second thing that we're doing is we're
actually socializing college students
into enjoying and understanding where
they can follow science once the four
science courses they might take as a
non-major over and that could be the new
york times that give you popular science
books that could be magazines like seed
magazine or scientific american